[Music]
it's funny because you're such an
interesting character and like you and
and you seem a typical of what one might
assume from a from an NFL well well
that's the thing is that a lot of people
have this assumption of NFL players is
kind of knuckle-dragging troglodytes
because you really only hear about the
bad players you know those are the guys
who make the news and there's a lot of
very smart NFL players in the locker
room you know I've had lots of great
conversations but you don't hear about
them because they take care of business
and then they go home right who wants to
report on that that's it's not fun it
doesn't make for great stores make for a
good story and so you know I think what
everyone saw with me was that all of a
sudden is like oh the the swearing they
can latch on to and then you know and
then the human rights stuff and and I
guess you generally don't you know you
don't hear about that in the news and I
feel as role models you know we should
be good role models not bad role models
that's terrific well the other thing is
that it's that you yourself are not gay
and it's not like anyone you don't have
any family member this is something you
took on is just this is a this is our
human rights issue right right to me
this is a smaller subset of human rights
as a whole and the thing is is that
societies that don't practice empathy if
you look at the historical record every
single civilization has failed and
they've all gone down whether it's
conflict from within by oppressing your
own people or conflict from without
trying to pick a fight with someone and
eventually losing and really the root
cause of that is not being able to put
yourself in someone else's shoes right
and it's it's empathy it's treat other
people the way you'd like to be treated
and I'm seeing that a lot in our society
and I would prefer that we don't go down
the drain and instead we endure as a
civilization
[Applause]
yeah I gotta take the opposing viewpoint
that was advocate oh yeah I think it's I
think we've Americans had a good run
it's time to go uh you know we had a
good couple years I want to talk about
you personally cuz I found this really
fascinating you were a you're quite an
avid online gamer we were actually
talking about this a little bit before
the show and you've ranked third like
nationally in dungeon progression I
don't even know what that is yeah so I'm
about to nerd everyone out here which
will be amazing I'm sure most the
audience will probably get it
so I played World of Warcraft for a very
long time and I was in a raiding guild
and in raiding the goal of dungeon
progression is to defeat the bosses it's
kind of like solving a puzzle each boss
has different mechanics right and I was
in a hardcore raiding guild which meant
we took it very very seriously and so at
one point we were third in the United
States in terms of raiding progression
which meant we stayed up very late at
night and kept pounding our heads
against these bosses over and over until
we beat them that's incredible so it's
amazing because you're a player in the
NFL but you're it seems like your true
dream what you're most proud of is that
you've rated third nationally in dungeon
progression well in the really funny
part is that is the only time in my life
I've actually dropped the hey I'm an NFL
player card rise when I applied to the
rating guild and I really wanted to get
in so I said I'm in the NFL let me in
and they're like oh my god to that vote
player is playing so let's let him in
now what I wanted to you also play with
tabletop miniatures I don't even know
what that is uh yeah so tabletop
miniatures they're the little plastic
computer figurines or about yay high and
you put them together and then you paint
them then you put them on the tabletop
and face off against someone else so
your generals commanding your armies and
you know it's awesome wait wait
face off how you do you throw them look
no it's you guys ice you know it's like
chess right yeah yeah yeah like chess
like kind of chess and risk combined and
you know each one has their different
stats and you roll dice you're going to
levels of nerd I've never approached its
uh player buyer this football is how I
fund my nerdy hobbies I have to ask you
quickly at least two currently active
pro athletes have come out since your
letter do you feel like there's a shift
obviously nationally there's a shift but
you're you you feel like in the NFL
there's like there's a shift in sports
in general yeah I do I do I think it's a
sign of society as a whole really just
moving towards more tolerance and more
acceptance and the NFL is a young man's
game you know it's it's guys coming in
from college they're 21 22 and so as
each year progresses you see the younger
and younger generations coming up
through the ranks and these guys have
been raised with gay teammates with gay
family members with gay friends and to
them it's not a big deal they're like
what is the issue here we should be more
worried about the economy or the wars
that we're in a different perspective
yeah it's it's gay marriage who cares
about that what what do I care if
someone else does with their life when
I'm free to do what I want with my life
right and so you're really starting to
see that that progression well that's a
hopeful message yeah I know it's good
and old people die off and the young
people take over there are sown old
people are some here they're like
they don't know who I am who's that
awful host